Oh,
I spend at least a week,
a year where I go off to the screen,
keep us phd.
Theses and new things are going on in
the field.
You'll believe the prime ingredient of
his success was his early fascination
with computers.
You have to understand when you spend
your time thinking intensely about a
field and how from a very young age,
uh,
what's my cases?
You know,
it's 13 or 14 when I started to get
involved.
Uh,
that's where you can do great things is
because your mind has really gotten into
it.
You,
you understand that
one of the ideas that excite you or is
it just customers?
Customers first,
second is last a century a company.
If you want to grow,
I believe you should find a great
opportunity.
But today this was now lack opportunity
that today if you want to be a Greek
company,
think about what problem you can solve.
It's not the catch the opportunity.
It's about solving the social risk
problems.
If you,
because companies like Alibaba where
brings so fast,
it's very difficult for one opportunity
that can make us lost
such a organization.
Who is the power power by ink to net was
millions and millions of smes with 400
million consumers.
What kind of problem can solve and uh,
I'm excited.
Anything you mentioned about cloud
computing and talking about a more bio
things,
anything that's happened in the USA is
going to happen in China.
There is an amazing degree to which
people's ambitions get beaten out of
them in these,
in these,
in these top universities.
If I look at what people thought my
senior year in high school,
it was sort of like,
we're very ambitious.
They'd all these ideas what they were
going to do.
And if you looked at the same people at
a sort of college plus five years,
sort of nine years later,
let's say,
it was amazing how much things have been
ratcheted down.
So I,
I do think there's something problematic
where all the talented people go to
these schools.
They're sort of evaluated on the same
terms and at the end,
uh,
at the end,
a lot of ambitions are beaten out of
them.
Know,
probably the,
the one that I think is even worse for
people than Harvard in this respect,
uh,
might be,
might be Caltech where you have these
brilliant math,
physics people and after four years
where you're in the middle of your
class,
you're convinced that the most you can
do with your life has become a blind
engineer at Lockheed.
And maybe you can go into mid level
management 20 years later.
And so that,
that is,
that sort of is characteristic of a,
of what I think has happened and what,
what,
what I think we need to somehow find a
way back to is,
is this idea that,
um,
that there's not just a single track,
that there are very different things you
can do.
You know,
the question,
you know,
what truth do you know that nobody
agrees with you on the,
the,
the sort of career version of this is
what,
what are you really at that other people
aren't that good at or,
or something like that.
And that's a,
and that's somehow gets discouraged by
this,
by this incredible homogenization.
Yeah.
And big ambitions get discouraged.
I think that you think every way the EU,
then everyone runs true of all of us.
I suppose we decide we can make it in
certain line and do things a little,
you know,
move ahead step by step.
But the kind of,
yeah,
there's always the ambition to be a
founder that if that seems to be knocked
out,
the whole,
both the institutions and the mindset
that permeates the institutions is
almost a denial that that ambition is
reasonable or even possible.
Well,
there's a sense that um,
there are all these people who are ahead
of you.
So there's always this sense,
there's so many people who are,
uh,
who are much better or just as good as
you.
So who are you to think that you can do
anything on anything different?
And obviously when everybody starts to
think that nobody does anything,
and in fact it becomes self fulfilling
once again,
you know,
for me,
so much of the lesson that,
that I,
I feel like I've learned is I feel like
it's really hard to decide to start a
company.
Right.
You know,
facebook,
I didn't start it to start a company.
I started it because I really wanted
this thing personally and I believed
that it should exist globally.
Although I wasn't quite sure that that
we would be able to play a role in doing
that.
It was mostly just through kind of like
wanting to build it and having it be
this hobby and getting people around me
excited that it eventually kind of
evolved into and got the momentum to
become a company.
But I never really understood the
psychology of deciding that you want to
start a company before you understand
what you want to do.
And this gets back to the question of
why did we,
why did we first open it at colleges
that had competitors?
I have this big fear I think of getting
locked into doing things that aren't
actually the most impactful things.
I mean to me this is like the trait that
entrepreneurs have is they just have
this like laser like ability to go find
where they can have the most impact.
And you know when you take on a new
project,
especially if you hire people or start a
company,
you're doing that project.
And I mean there,
there are ways,
there are obviously different ways that
it can exit and all that.
But,
um,
I think having the flexibility to
explore a lot of different things,
which you can do when you're in college,
which is one of the amazing things about
being in college is you can work on all
these hobbies,
um,
and,
and code a lot of stuff and try a lot of
different things.
It's this amazing flexibility that I
think most people take for granted.
And once you decide,
okay,
I'm going to start a company,
I'm going to do it with someone else,
you immediately now need to convince
someone else if you want to change your
mind on something.
And I think people really undervalue the
option value and flexibility.
I think explore what you want to do
before committing is really like the,
the key thing and keep yourself
flexible.
Um,
and no,
I think that that's,
I mean agree,
but I think you can definitely do that
within the framework of a company.
But I think you have to be wary about
starting a company,
um,
to rigidly because you're,
you're going to change what you do.
I mean,
people talk about pivots all the time as
if it's like it doesn't,
didn't your thing didn't work.
So you pivoted.
Facebook pivoted many times.
Um,
it just,
that,
you know,
we kind of,
we were college and then we were not
college and then we were just a website
and then we were a platform.
Right?
And you're going to change what you do.
There's another word for the kind of
pivots you were talking about.
Expansions.
Hell No.
What people usually mean by pivoting.
Well,
you know,
flexibility.
Follow your instincts.
Very easy to say.
Incredibly difficult to do.
A little more context.
Everybody,
when they're wondering about what they
should do after college or after
university,
you have the weight of expectations on
your shoulders.
You have college bills that you might
have to pay.
You have parents who have expectations
for you in a particular direction.
And whether you like it or not,
subconsciously you carry all that stuff
with you.
And if you want to go in a different
direction from what you've been spent
the previous 20,
25 years,
he realized almost being programmed to
go and do.
That's a very difficult thing to do.
What matters eventually is the quality
of the investment decisions made and the
acuity with with which those are made.
And it's somewhat similar to the analogy
that people used to make when newspapers
were read more frequently than they are
today,
which is not to get sucked up into
believing your own headlines.
And so I think especially in today's
era,
and humility also goes along way
particularly in which if you don't make
decisions correctly,
can a hand you out a right royal
spanking?
Uh,
no matter how high your public profile,
do you believe that there'll be another
steve job in this five to 10 years,
uh,
know any more than I believe there'll be
another Larry Page or mark Zuckerberg or
Bill Gates.
They're each very distinctive
personalities.
Now,
if the question is,
is there somebody whose name we don't
know today,
who 20 years from now will be very well
known because of a company that he or
she started?
Absolutely.
Yes I do.
I think sequoia is the preeminent
venture firm.
I don't,
um,
I think,
I think I always feel we're always one
step away from going out of business and
um,
that we can never take anything for
granted and that we're only as good as
our next investment.
The advice that people should follow
their instincts,
whether I could say a little bit more
about that.
I think it helps if you try and enter an
environment where you think you can
learn a lot,
whether that's inside the organization.
It doesn't have to have to be a company.
It can be,
uh,
be,
some other organization or around people
that you particularly admire that you
can learn a lot from.
And I think that just helps expand
horizons.
So also gives the individual a sense of
what excellence is really like how
realistic is it for a company to do b to
c and B,
two b at the same time?
Uh,
we,
I,
I'm sure there examples of companies
that have pulled it off.
Um,
I just think right at the beginning you
have to concentrate on doing one thing
super well on.
Once you've done that,
uh,
the second thing becomes easier,
particularly if you're dealing with,
it's one thing to sell precisely the
same product to both audiences.
And if you can do that,
bless your heart.
Uh,
it's a,
it's a good thing to do,
but I think it's very [inaudible] you've
got to tailor the product differently.
I think that's a very dangerous thing
for a company to do.
Uh,
right at the start,
you know,
it's no coincidence apple under Steve
Jobs was not prepared to compromise a
change and alter its products to please
corporations.
They would,
um,
uh,
build products and if corporations,
and it's wanted to buy them,
so be it,
but they weren't going to come up with,
with special products.
So it was an approach that,
uh,
obviously served them very well.
And then as you know,
there are plenty of examples of other
companies that have over time,
uh,
succeeded with two different sorts of
distribution channels.
Plenty of examples of that.
But at the beginning,
I think simplicity is a virtue
cause I think that's really important,
especially for young people to actually
do that self assessment and find that
passion.
Do you have any advice?
I think many,
many kids and many grownups do figure
out,
uh,
over time what their passions are.
And sometimes we let our,
I don't think it's that hard.
I think what happens though sometimes is
that we let our intellectual selves
overrule those passions.
Uh,
and so that's what needs to be guarded
against.
Uh,
kids are very good about knowing what
their passions are.
I love that because I think I've seen
you described this way that you've
always maintained that sense of wonder.
I think that's what kids have,
but we lose it somehow along the way.
Everybody,
it's a gift.
If you can keep your childlike sense of
wonder,
uh,
and it helps with creativity,
it helps to have fun.
Uh,
you know,
you laugh more and play more if you keep
that childlike sense of wonder.
What we're really focused on is thinking
long term,
putting the customer at the center of
our universe and inventing.
Those are the three big ideas I don't
think that you can invent on behalf of
customers unless you're willing to think
long term because a lot of invention
doesn't work.
If you're going to invent,
it means you're going to experiment to
have to think long term.
So these three ideas,
customer centricity,
long term thinking,
and a passion for invention,
those go together.
That's how we do it.
And by the way,
we have a lot of fun doing it that way.
Amazing about your successes,
that you actually,
your timing was good.
How does a,
an innovator actually identify that
historical momentum,
that Kitty Hawk moment you breathe,
you recognize what was happening with
the Internet and you said,
you know what,
there's actually a room for me to start
with books and then move on.
How do you do that?
How do you find the time and the
momentum,
the Zeitgeists,
I think everybody has their own passion,
their own thing that they're interested
in.
And then you're very alert to the things
that,
that are in the sphere of influence of
that passion.
So your passion has led you to change
the world,
frankly with Amazon,
but yet you've got blue origin,
you've got pesos,
explorations.
Why can't somebody like you just rest on
your loral go?
Well,
I,
you know,
I love what I do.
I also have four kids.
I have wife that I love.
I have a lot of passions and interests.
Um,
but I,
one of them is the pace of change.
Um,
I love the fact that I get to work with
these smart,
big smart teams.
Uh,
the people I work with are so smart and
they all,
they're self selected for loving to
invent on behalf of customers.
And so,
you know,
it's not,
uh,
I do,
I love every moment of every day.
No,
that's why they call it work.
There's,
you know,
there's always,
there are things that I,
that I don't enjoy,
but if I'm really objective about it and
I look at it,
I'm so lucky to be working alongside all
these passionate people and I love it.
How do you remain nimble?
Because there is somebody in their dorm
room who could eat you up for lunch the
next day.
You know,
my belief on this is,
first of all,
that's completely correct and you can't,
uh,
it can never show anybody that that
can't happen.
But I think if you have a customer
centric culture that cures a lot of ills
because we wake up,
if,
let's say you're the leader in a
particular arena,
if you're competitor focused and you're
already the leader,
then where does your energy come from?
Whereas if you're customer focused and
you're already the leader,
customers are never satisfied.
So you always,
if you're customer focused,
you're always waking up.
How can we make that customer say,
wow,
how can we,
you know,
our energy,
our passion,
we want to impress our customers.
We want them to say,
wow,
is that kind of divine discontent comes
from observing customers and noticing
that,
you know,
things can,
so what was the sense that people have
that it's really hard to come with the
answers.
All the answers have already been
discovered in one way or another.
And I think that's not the case.
And I,
I sort of,
um,
I sort of divided things up into
conventions,
which are things everybody knows to be
true.
The other extreme,
there are mysteries,
things that nobody can figure out and in
between are these things that I call
secrets are things that you could figure
out.
They're hard,
but if you really work at it,
you could,
you could figure something out.
And,
um,
and one one thought that I have is that
there are many secrets left to be
discovered.
I actually think that this is a somewhat
nonconventional view because I think the
conventional view is that most secrets
have been discovered and that there's
nothing new to find.
And so,
uh,
and this is certainly is,
it is true,
certainly certain domains,
but I think most things are not like
that.
And I think there are a lot of fields
where new things can be found.
Um,
we're often discouraged by sort of a
version of globalization.
We think they're,
you know,
7 billion other people in the world.
And there will always be someone who
will have already thought of it.
And if no one will have thought of it
before us,
it must be almost impossibly hard.
And so it ends up being this sort of
self fulfilling thing where we don't
even try.
And I think,
I do think the only people who will
discover secrets are people who work at
it and who tried doing it.
And I,
I think that many of these,
um,
great companies have something like this
at the core that's,
it's some,
some domain of knowledge,
some area where people think they can
figure out a lot more at,
at,
at paypal,
we were very interested in this and the
intersection of money and cryptography.
Could you create a new digital currency
on the Internet?
And um,
and you know,
it was a fairly idiosyncratic field
were,
you know,
small number of people working on it.
There's a,
you know,
financial,
cryptography community,
um,
and you could sort of understand the
field you'd get to the frontiers and you
could,
uh,
you could,
you could explore it quite a bit more.
And so,
so that,
that,
so I think the second idea I want to
leave you with is there still is a
frontier left and the frontiers not
infinitely far away.
There's certain places where the
frontier has been close of
geographically it's kind of closed,
but there are many places where you can
still get to the frontier.
And it's actually,
uh,
there are many directions you can go
with a frontier as close and where
there's a lot left to be left to be
discovered.
You have developed as at least profile
as a young man in a hurry.
You know,
all the rough elbows at,
you know,
I think it's improved,
if,
how should I put it?
Um,
we look at all of the cities and we know
that the transportation systems there
are just not,
they're not serving everybody's needs.
I mean,
even here in New York with a great mass
transit system,
there are still two and a half million
cars going over those bridges every day.
And so we just believe we can help the
city do better.
I guess most,
most successful entrepreneurs are not
waiting for it to come to their success
and not waiting for progress.
Um,
we are generally a little bit,
um,
forward leaning when it comes to trying
to make progress happen.
For me it's about problem solving and
loving to solve problems.
And so if you are passionate about
solving problems,
and in some,
sometimes I just like to describe this
as like imagine a really great math
professor with no problems to solve,
right?
The great a great math professors,
somebody who,
who wants the hardest problems,
who wants to solve them and love solving
them.
That's Kinda how I feel about my work.
And so it's not about a man in a hurry.
It's more about really interesting
problems in the world and how do you
lean into them and solve things that
people maybe thought weren't even
possible to solve.
And that's fun.
You know,
for us,
we don't really aspire to be somebody
other than ourselves.
And part of being ourselves as sort of
reimagining the way things could be
done.
So we like to take the impossible.
We like to take the old way of doing
things and just completely change it.
That's part of who we are.
Um,
but I mean there are great ceos,
great founders,
great leaders out there and there's,
there's something to learn from all of
them.
In fact,
there's something to learn from the ones
that aren't great too.
Like again,
you know,
everybody sees success,
they see failure and we see that
personally and we should learn from it.
But why not learn from other people's
success and failure?
There's something to learn from all of
them.
I mean,
it depends how you look at it,
but when you have sort of this,
this problem solving culture,
uh,
the core group sort of depends on the
problem that's being solved.
And so it's very dynamic what that core
group is and on what problem.
Um,
I have 10,
11 direct reports and then depending on
what the problems of the day,
our can determine how many of those
folks are in a particular problem.
And by the way,
a lot of problems getting solved that
I'm not involved in.
And so figuring out what,
which ones that you go into,
how do you prioritize it?
Um,
how do you get to the future faster?
Is is one of the things we spend a lot
of times sort of architecting
silicon valley and the sort of the state
of Silicon Valley.
Do you think it's at a high point of,
of invention right now or to plateau or
at a low point or,
well,
I think they're jumping off.
It's funny,
it reminds me like I,
you know,
look,
I've been an entrepreneur since the mid,
late nineties and I remember in 2001 I
was raising money.
This is the host raising money in the
fall of 2001 for a networking software
company.
And I remember going to one of the,
one of the restaurants in Palo Alto,
which used to be bustling and like you'd
have to book,
like get a reservation like a month
ahead of time or something.
And it was empty.
It was like tumbleweeds.
And I remember a vc telling me that all
the things that could be invented is
2001,
all the things that could be invented in
software had been invented and that
there was no more innovation left and
software and right.
So that irrational sort of,
there's irrational exuberance and
irrational pessimism.
Uh,
I'm just generally an optimist.
I just think there's just problems to be
solved everywhere.
And once you solve them,
you already see what's,
you know,
I'd like to say boredom is only the
result of a lack of imagination.
And you know,
the minute you solve one thing,
you just sit down for a few minutes and
then you come up with like 10 more
ideas.
So,
uh,
so I think I'm an optimist.
Like there's just so much more to do.
Um,
I think what's very interesting,
and maybe this is because of our global
reach and just where we've been is
silicon valley I think has been sort of
the,
the North Star for innovation or,
or,
or the hub of innovation globally.
And I think that is no longer going to
be a thing.
I think if we go five years out,
you're going to start to see hubs of
innovation.
This is about to be real,
at least with a couple major ones.
Right?
Yeah.
Was going to ask you one more question.
Was there a time was up,
um,
you're worth a lot of money now.
What's the most expensive thing you've
bought?
Hmm.
Well,
I think what a lot of people don't know
is that I've never sold a single uber
share.
So,
um,
the most expensive thing I bought,
I bought before uber started and it's my
home
and it was right around a million bucks.
Okay.
So I got a mortgage in fact that you
still have a mortgage.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Fabulous.
Thank you so much,
Travis.
Okay.
Chung Kong is the Cantonese word for the
young.
See China's longest river.
And it is more than just a name for
lean.
You got a young team,
like I said,
the [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] the
the World Cup.
Yeah.
Soin each over.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
Paul.
Yeah.
Michael [inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] you him,
boy,
you [inaudible].
Okay,
so you like play hotel.
What's up?
Yo?
What?
Walking in.
Get Homesick there.
A toy
chicken bedrooms.
Yeah.
Yet they,
then you link those
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].
Hi Morty,
though.
K O e.
O.
[inaudible] the Taiwan.
They get turned over.
Hi.
Hosts do bulger.
What's the lesson?
The lesson is say,
where he can manage the company also in
west and the key pieces of advice.
Li Ka Shing.
It's passing on to his son.